Jesus Christ how's it going citizens of
the reject Nation John here for another
solo movie reaction and this is what
I've been looking forward to for a long
time because uh as many of you know but
some of you probably don't over on
patreon we cover a bunch of TV shows and
movies and whatnot and a lot of that
stuff is Anime related or at least a
good you know sort of section of it is
dedicated to anime and this was a show
that I've been following for the first
season took a break when the season
ended and since have been you know sort
of occupied with a whole bunch of other
things and it's taken me a while to get
to this point but it was always part of
the plan to check out Mugen train the
hit the Smash Hit Demon Slayer movie um
this is a bit of a risk because as
you'll notice we don't really cover a
ton of anime here on YouTube it's a
pretty tricky process and we have
received copyright strikes in the past
for attempting to do so which take six
months or more to get removed from your
account they can be a big pain in the
behind and so uh this video in and of
itself is a bit of a risk so if you're
seeing it that means we did it so leave
a like while you can that would be very
much appreciated helps out the channel
leave a comment uh with your thoughts or
anything that you feel the need to
correct me on or enlighten me about
there's probably going to be a few of
those moments as well don't forget to
subscribe to the channel hit that
notification Bell so you can keep track
of anything and everything we have
coming out that you might be interested
in and of course as I mentioned before
if you want to get the full experience
with me come on over to patreon.com the
real rejects bring your own copy sync up
with the time code get the complete
experience plus check out all of our
other shows and movies that we have over
their music videos and such we got
reaction highlights as well as
full-length watch alongs for a bunch a
bunch of that stuff and last but
certainly not least thank you to the
team over at prepper for doing the
reaction highlights on this video on
countless other videos across the
channel they are hugely hugely
instrumental in everything you see
before you in these reaction videos so
uh much much love to prepper and without
further Ado I got my muzon kibutsuji hat
right here ready to go it's definitely
going to stay on for the entire video
just you watch let's do this
so beautiful God
just like the whole artwork on this show
all the environments and stuff like is
absolutely gorgeous
foreign
come on kids hop aboard
lens flare like all the subtle
flourishes
[Laughter]
someone's getting a model trained for
Christmas
[Music]
because I'm about to save your asses
from demons in a few minutes
it's literally the least I could do
you recognize his hair
yeah see
[Music]
man
[Music]
I gotta watch a whole making of just on
how they
do these kinds of shots like wow
who might
you might no uh hey there
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
yeah this guy's dead man this guy's like
rotting already
[Music]
wasting no time boy
oh
foreign
[Music]
Wowie
that was awesome bro
oh now you want to be The Apprentice
oh look at those two
both of those two
oh dude
oh
what's up
oh so twisted
[Music]
samurita
oh buddy
[Music]
cool man
[Music]
you know
this is a sound effect
s
[Music]
so
nasty but so cool
kids
Monica
[Music]
uh little do you know
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course the mighty train it's a mighty
trained to peed
okay
[Music]
this is definitely my favorite dream
s
[Music]
Jesus
thank you for the encouragement dad
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh that's messed up
it's very creatively messed up
um
oh wow
oh damn
oh no
still a child but but oh no
[Music]
oh I'm so conflicted right now
realize it
oh
foreign
just jump off of something High
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus mythical
my true form
foreign
[Music]
memories
oh
hardest steps you have to take
it
you've been waiting around a little bit
my dude no to you
meanwhile in the opposite of that
yeah you picked the wrong person's mind
to invade foreign
yes you have to grope him
specifically
[Music]
laughs
of course his subconscious would be
like shrewd that way because that makes
a lot of sense that the way zenitsu
channels his power
children
oh
geez
[Music]
[Laughter]
wake up
[Music]
oh no
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chooses truth
oh here it comes
[Music]
[Music]
oh nice
foreign
[Music]
they're so good at depicting that like
careening motion
[Music]
[Music]
excuse oh my God
this is Live Die repeating over here
[Music]
yeah I mean my dude can't be afraid of
much now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
this is a dream
yeah I was about to say it was too easy
[Music]
oh what the [ __ ]
got all that joking up at the front
actually
it wasn't too far off
it's like the blob
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
explosive Awakening
[Music]
sweetness me
foreign
just looking at this I'm like I bet that
smells awful
this whole thing must feel would smell
like
sweat and viscera and decay
it's all the more disturbing to think
that they're actually inside of
this demon
who's now become like a flesh tube
oh yeah
yeah see what nezuko can do with this
[Music]
God
this is like Resident Evil Zero
[Music]
yeah buddy that's so cool
I like that no matter how dejected he
gets
has always got that confident smile
that was a hospital my friend
in action
s
the yellow boy careful there is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is too many hands
foreign
I like that Tundra gets him enough to
just be like sure okay you're the leader
whatever
oh it's it's [ __ ] up spinal column
ugh
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
okay
[Music]
there's got to be a way to practice like
tunnel vision
[Music]
oh Daniel
this is
[Laughter]
I bet that mask is helping out
[Music]
wow
that's so cool
[Music]
God how much matter does this demon have
at its disposal
[Music]
like a whack-a-mole
[Music]
[Music]
oh geez
[Music]
whoa no oh
beautiful
oh
what the most selfless
if I die then that guy will be a
murderer and I don't want that for him
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no who is this like the bottom of the
upper
upper three
he's here to [ __ ] [ __ ] up dog
[Music]
oh
that bisect oh
that's like saw five
foreign
I can tell we have no common interests
[Music]
I like this rangoku quite a bit
jeez there's an ultimatum for you oh
oh
damn
[Laughter]
that's cool
they could
[Music]
oh
my God
CQC
s
[Music]
thank you
cousin of Stephen blazing universe
oh I'm starting to get nervous
oh
my God
total concentration breathing man
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ER
disorder
[Music]
no yeah
I don't think so nope yeah oh damn it oh
[Music]
that like warping effect on the sides of
the screen
that like lensing thing
there's that spirit in the face
[Music]
yeah you are
[Music]
oh
cool
oh my God
[Applause]
oh the twist
Jesus ah
huh
it's like a it's like a mushroom cloud
um
words to live by
[Music]
e
foreign
[Music]
no you don't
tightening all of his abs around your
arm
yoga
[Music]
yeah not so tough now are you not so
tough at dawn
[Music]
Move Your Body
[Music]
no get grab him
[Music]
don't be a [ __ ]
clearly ready for the sun yeah
I ate something
[Music]
ah you're just rational like you're just
bargaining dude
[Music]
oh dude
yeah and don't you forget it foreign
[Music]
mama
foreign
you can like see the sunlight shining
through his skin
[Music]
foreign
foreign
Focus pulling
oh
what a gorgeous shot
[Music]
I mean
be at peace
oh and that's okay
oh
dude
my eyes are sweating
God and he's just still sitting there
Jesus
[Music]
look how torn up the ground is
[Music]
wow what a note to end on
I mean obviously you know there's gonna
be more but still
interesting like somber tone to leave
off on
makes it feel like the whole movie is
dedicated to him
Goku
yeah they get good music for these man
these themes are rousing it's a very
cool character I mean you know like we
met him briefly in the first season I
feel like and then you know to really I
mean in a lot of ways this is kind of
his movie I mean tundra and Company
certainly are on the journey certainly
have a lot to learn but like I feel like
he is the centerpiece he is the the sort
of
core soul of this movie and it's like
the the top ranking guy like just tore
through the veil of everything we'd the
whole situation we'd just been in with
uh you know lower one or whatever that
was and uh he pierced his uh he pierced
the core of his soul
and it's interesting too the way that
these songs I mean I'm sitting here
watching the credits and they're like
lyrics but it's interesting the way that
these songs
re like they go out of their way I I
feel like in a more direct sense than we
do here with various things to like
really make sure that the themes of the
music match the themes of what you're
watching there's a lot of perseverance
and there's a lot of grappling with
grief
you know appealing to
the strength deep within I feel like
that's a it's a heavy theme in a lot of
anime things and especially here is the
sort of dig deep you know like what does
it take to dig deep what is your
motivation for digging deep what
Touchstone can you call upon loved his
sword too I mean his whole look is great
like I
I like the designs of the hashira and
the demons too I mean like the designs
of everything are really gorgeous in
this show but yeah like to spend so much
time with the flame hashira and to have
you know all these different
just like you know the design of his
whole his eyes the color of his eyes you
know the different uh Shades in his hair
the hilt of the sword and everything
all right that's all she wrote Let's
chitty chat about it all right my
friends we did it we did it we rode the
Mugen train at long last uh you know
it's it's almost funny to be here now
after so much time and thinking back on
the early stages of the pandemic when
this movie was like tearing up the box
office when there was literally almost
no box office to tear up uh but yeah man
I had a great time with this I really
enjoyed this I mean I feel like one of
the first questions that comes to
anyone's mind when you're dealing with
an anime movie or a movie based on
anything that you know is from an
episodic format to one degree or another
I feel like the the question looms is it
just like one long episode or does it
really feel like a movie and I think
this movie did a nice job at at least
Bridging the Gap and and kind of coming
towards the middle of that for me I mean
I feel like you know looking at the show
and from what I understand this is like
the first chunk of season two is like a
semi-expanded version of this which I
find almost better ironic that there is
you know that this movie can be seen in
an elongated form as if a movie wasn't
the whole kind of place to do that
um and as such I mean I am curious to
know what was taken out and what will be
added back by that experience and hey if
anybody is a patron and and you know I
imagine we will continue with season two
uh let me know what you want to see if
you want to see you know uh those
episodes again with all that added
context or if I should just you know
watch the first episode and then catch
up with the rest of my own time until
it's new stuff and then go from there
but that's a sidebar um but yeah you
know like it's interesting because you
know to know that this does exist in the
episodic format with I'm sure some of
the flourishes that are unique to that
uh you know side of the medium uh I
thought this did again nicely to justify
itself as a movie I'm kind of torn
actually I mean I feel like you know in
some ways knowing how arcs on Demon
Slayer are uh you know this definitely
feels like it I could easily see how you
could dice this up and make this Arc a
compilation however uh I thought this as
a story for the movie theaters was nice
because it you know hones in on the core
of these characters and in a way it is
very much urengoku or kyojiro's movie
you know I mean so much of the focus is
on him we're meeting him ostensibly at
least intimately for the first time
we've seen him in the past you know we
we've got a taste of them but this is
the first time we're really like
spending with him and I feel like there
is a tendency at least thinking back on
some of the other like anime spin-off
movies that we've seen you know to kind
of highlight a side or a sort of spoken
of character and make it yeah a vignette
mostly about them for the main Arc of
the story but then also you know showing
how it enhances the journeys of our uh
Heroes who are you know gonna be the
through lines of the show and whatnot
and as such I mean I got really pulled
into his story and I really liked the uh
Motif the device of the dreams and that
was something that felt kind of
especially cinematic like I really
enjoyed the way at the outset you know
you meet him he's eating the food
delicious you know it's like a quirky
situation picking up from right where we
left off at the end of uh season one
with them on the train main platform you
know evading the police and then you
know you get right into this demon fight
and uh you know as first it's like okay
we're wasting no time you know they hey
they Triumph and then they all take a
nap and everything's great and of course
you know it's a little too easy and then
you break into
um this motif of the dreams which makes
way for a lot of fun and games and a lot
of imaginative you know chaos and
craziness and disturbing imagery that
that anime is so good at delivering
um but it also you know is tied into the
roots of the characters and it's also
revealing of the characters and I
appreciated that we saw you know this
glimpse into uh uh kyojiro's past uh but
through the the lens of this dream so
that you can't a hundred percent tell if
it's even real per se but it is
indicative of you know what's truly
inside and I like that you know even
though you have this really dejected
moment this really discouraging moment
between uh kyodro and his father I'm
gonna use his names interchangeably so I
hope no one gets confused but yeah like
seeing this this heart crunching moment
where he's like I've made it to this you
know huge milestone I am you know the
flame hashira you know I achieved you
know one of the highest achievements you
know that that I could have you know and
his father's like you know I don't think
it's gonna make a difference you're not
I don't make a difference you don't make
a difference I don't really care you
know and it's so heart heart-rending and
it informs so much of the rest of the
movie because then you get those
subsequent moments showing the love from
his mother and you know that bond that
really fills that void left by his
father and also the way he seeks to
empower his little brother like his
dream in tanjiro's dream are are quite
similar I feel like uh in that yeah
they're they're both at home and they're
both you know with the realities and and
some of the more
um I don't know like uh idealized
aspects of their lives back at home and
I love how he empowers his little
brother he says you know even though hey
Dad wasn't receptive to what I just told
him at all you know like I'm still
really proud of you and you know no
matter what you choose to do with your
life I'm going to be supporting you and
we together you know even if we're apart
we're going to achieve like that was
really lovely and then to see that
transfer onto tanjiro and zenitsu and
inasuke through this experience and and
despite their initial reluctance I think
was really nice and a lot of fun and by
the end it's funny me and I was like I
wanted the tears I was almost there I
really really really was moved by The
End by his journey and again like
they're so good at doing that in anime
especially and and you know a lot of
Shonen has those recurring themes of
perseverance and sort of confronting and
embracing your core traumas and using
them as fuel to push yourself past your
limits and to achieve and so yeah like
by the end I just really love that
brotherly Bond and the way he takes them
under his wing and the way that you can
tell that his quirkiness while funny and
and kind of odd is built on something
real it's like he's unflappable well
he's determined he's a little above it
all but in a sense it makes sense and he
does you know manage to raise each of
you know our heroes up with that and uh
and yeah I like the way that he and
tanji are like there's that whole thing
about like you know the the water
hashira and the fire hashira like side
by side and even though you know right
now it's not like official even though
it's whatever he said it's been like so
long since that's been the case that
there have been you know but one of each
side by side you know as a member as
members you know of the main you know
active hashira uh getting to see them
together and getting to see tanjiro
switch back and forth between his water
breathing techniques as well as the
flame techniques like was really really
gratifying and then you know you see uh
uh kyojiro setting the example just with
again that being his expertise
um but again like even the use of the
elements I mean there's so many
beautiful and amazing looking fire
effects and I really like that yeah it's
like as you're exploring everyone's
dream you're getting a glimpse into how
they see life and what's valuable to
them and I really like the mechanics of
how the dreams worked I thought this had
a really nice grip on that too where
yeah they have these fantasies that
people were lulled into and and people
want to believe in some kind of
idealized fantasy but it's not infinite
and beyond that you know barrier or the
periphery The Edge is you know basically
their subconscious where the essence of
their soul is and so yeah I love that
that dividing line between like if you
just kill yourself in the dream or you
get killed in the dream and you're just
in the bubble you'll you'll probably
just wake up and you're fine but yeah if
somebody really pierces beneath to the
to the core of your soul like it's a
cool astral concept and uh and yeah the
way they realize that for everybody I
thought was really nice because yeah you
get obviously a nosuke like you know are
mostly supporting humorous bad at like
they're here to provide humor and
badassness in this movie they don't get
much in terms of the character meat or
growth which is fine because I really
enjoyed both of their moments I mean
zinitsu always cracks me up with his
like cowardly Antics although here I
mean was more badass than itsu uh you
know more just of him in the trance and
I appreciate again the way that they're
able to expand on and justify things
like that because in a breath as much as
I enjoy it it is like man this guy is
like in his waking form just so so so so
so so so
ill-suited to this and yet yeah when he
blacks out he is just deadly and I loved
that you know based on what we know
about his backstory and his training and
everything his subconscious is
essentially just this darkened void with
no anything like no even Echoes of love
just him you know it's it's almost it's
the opposite of the coward on the inside
it's the on edge like paranoid like
nobody's supposed to be in here except
for desuko and of course he's chasing as
it go around and nezuko too I mean like
she gets accepted by the end which I
really appreciated and even though
nobody's gonna hear that uh you know it
was very gratifying to have her join in
the fight you know just continue on her
mission of protecting any and all humans
and you know being in major asset in
terms of fighting with the actor demons
but yeah like that was very gratifying
and yeah just to see into especially
tanjiro's dreams because we spent you
know the most time there and again man
like the way that they capture the
elements like I love the the prologue
and the epilogue to this movie and
that's another thing that made it feel
very cinematic was having these somber
tones to begin and end the movie the
toll it's like we're going to see a lot
of badass demon fighting obviously and
we're gonna see some crazy blood demon
art and we're gonna see some crazy
imaginative stuff but at the beginning
and end it's really honed in on the toll
and I liked that um I always forget uh
uh oyakatasama there you go I always
that's one of the ones I I have to
commit full on to memory but yeah
um I really like that they start with
him being reflective and I mean he's
dying he's got this you know corrosive
disease and uh he's reflecting on the
fact that yeah like you know they're
more demon attacks and you know so many
people are going out there and fighting
and dying for this in this Mission with
the train as we later find out has
swallowed up so many people and so many
demon Slayers and you know just feeling
the weight of that and the way that
which you know he feels obviously like
he is the sort of guiding force of this
and as such you know people are sort of
fighting a communal battle but his
battle certainly as it is organized here
and yeah to have him feeling that toll
as a father would his children he's
sending off to war essentially like I
really like that tone and then coming to
the end where like even as uh uh uh
kyojiro is is bleeding out on the ground
he still finds the smile and he still
finds the means to you know encourage
tanjiro and the others to go on and you
know even despite you know the toll and
even despite what's hard about it and I
love that it all culminates uh with
lower three because two I mean what this
is doing for the show
is uh is setting up you know the the 12
kizuki even that much more we've seen a
couple of them up until now and those
have always been really striking really
unique uh battles and with you know very
interesting motifs and whatnot but uh
yeah here I feel like we're showing okay
so once we get to the to the top of the
lower ranks basically it released the
remaining lower ranks we see just how
formidable that can be but then you also
set the stage for the upper ranks and
just how much more impossible that seems
and so yeah as the Journey of kyojiro
through this and ultimately meeting this
match of like one of the you know
elitists of the elite villains like I
thought that story was really satisfying
and really nicely done and again like
our heroes are more apprentices through
that but it does again touch on the core
of their journey and the mortality that
they face all the time and yeah like
kyojiro represents something that I
think all of them don't have I mean for
tundra it's like having a brother figure
who is like familial and who can impart
with who can be like a mentor in that
way it's like his dream takes him back
to his family to being at home to the
simple life to what he should be doing
despite all of this but what he cannot
uh you know lull into what he can't go
back to and what he can't hold on to so
strongly that he's you know not able to
move forward and uh you know you have
such these warm little tones with that
and uh and it it highlights that
contrast and then yeah you have kyojiro
to kind of fill that in in the president
even though
you know it's very painful at the end
like everybody cries because everybody
was touched by this guy and yeah like
zinitsu and and uh in usuke too like the
the the traumas and the and the you know
loneliness and
um you know this sort of ostracization
that's a random ass word but yeah like
the ways in which they've been shunned
in the past they all have a reason to
gravitate towards this guy and
especially after that initial display of
uh you know demons slaying where they're
all just so enamored like yeah it was
nice to see them all really uh get at
least a little bit of emotional uh sort
of fill up from that because yeah when
it comes right down to it like I like
that you have this this double this
two-fold approach from the demons like
with uh I think his name emu uh uh you
know upper or lower one uh you know his
whole thing about like you know humans
are selfish and they want to you know
believe in you know these one uh these
very satisfying fantasies and and that's
the perfect way to slip away in a
delusion that is pleasant and you know
it won't even matter I'm doing you a
favor this is going to be nice and and
you can see like I love that too are
they kids or are they adults the people
who are you know like tying them up with
the ropes and even that I thought was
like a cool Motif to get them you know
into the dreams so that they can you
know break in and do the damage they
have to do and uh yeah just like that
whole idea that people willingly go that
way and then watching as each of our
characters core motivations arise I mean
yeah we get those glimpses into their
subconsciousness
um but each of them you know does it a
different way it's like in usuke he just
like runs the whole Onslaught off like
you picked with the rock dude wrong
dream uh and you know eventually is is
woken up by nezuko but yeah he puts up a
strong fight and zinitsu obviously is
like very disconcerting in the way only
he could be but I love the contrast with
tanjiro the way he leads the guy to it
and basically with compassion and love
shows him the fragility and the beauty
of the thing he's about to destroy and
he overcomes the guy with emotion and he
truly like cured he doesn't just like
fight the guy off he like kind of cures
something within that guy that that you
know uh left him vulnerable to this
fiendish want for the sleep for the
dream for the escape from his real
circumstances the tuberculosis or
whatever that was and then yeah to bring
that you know for them to Vanquish uh
you know this this crazy you know dream
inducing train villain and of course you
get your Kaiju Battle with your crazy
ass eyes I really like the body horror
stuff with that character in particular
and it's interesting too I mean this
show obviously has a lot of cutting edge
blending of drawn animation and CG
animation and I'm always there are
always things I really appreciate about
it and they're always things that I feel
like we're not quite a hundred percent
seamless with yet but I mean this is
something that yeah I'm like I get why
they see G did and I do again I go back
and forth because some of the things
especially with the tentacles in the
eyes it's like you can get Reflections
and textures and things that you can't
in the same way as animation and I do
appreciate that they kind of use
lighting and shading and Line work to
make it look as if it's kind of in that
style of hand-drawn but I feel like it
often Falls somewhere in the middle and
I can't exactly tell why if that's like
literally the design choice or if it's
just because you your eye knows but I
did think a lot of what they did on the
train still was spectacular it
definitely reminded me of like Resident
Evil Zero like being on the train with
like huge icky bio Creations but yeah
with a more philosophical angle and I
always love the way
especially the big villain the big like
kizuki characters like fade off and have
these like soliloquies at the end these
sort of despairing soliloquies and
there's always this sort of
compassionate but you know Melancholy
moment as they fade off and so yeah you
have that initial uh attack that
Onslaught basically saying yeah these
humans are selfish and they're going to
you know want to succumb to this it'll
be easy as pie and then each of them or
at least tanjiro and uh and uh kyojiro
is sort of standing up in their own way
and it's like he is so strong he is so
finely tuned and trained that you know
he doesn't wake up right away but he
does have just like Spider Sense enough
to pin you know the one girl against uh
you know just kind of hold her up there
and stop the attack
um and then tanjiro like I love that he
sees his reflection in water that's his
you know main technique uh I I really
enjoyed that that's kind of what helps
wake him up just a nice flourish a nice
in-character flourish
um and and yeah the the ways in which
then they spread that twos initsu and
and you know osuke and they're able to
just walk that you know fragile line
with the theme because then you get to
lower three or upper threes you get to
Upper three and his whole thing is like
you know as he's fighting rengoku he's
like you are Elite you are one of the
best you should be immortal because
think how much better you could be like
I love that touch of him trying to
persuade him trying to get him on the
team like Hey what how much more would
musan kibuchi uh uh reward me for
bringing in one of the toughest of our
enemies like I loved that and the way
that it comes down to the sunrise and
after this whole philosophical debate
you know kyodoro puts up like the
ultimate fight and the guy [ __ ] out
and runs off into the woods and I mean
of course what else would he have done
but uh oh man like it's the perfect kind
of like maddening end and also too again
you're like oh with this with you know
kyojiro with rangoku's help like this
was
oh you know like without the sun it
probably would have been a failure or he
would have probably died anyways like
what chance do we have moving forward
and that's a great builder of stakes
um so yeah man I thought this did really
nicely to bring all those things you
like about Demon Slayer all the crazy uh
techniques they throw down and the
animation flourishes and again those
applying to the action sequences and and
that sense of motion and vitality and
grit and intensity uh you know the
horror stuff the body horror stuff the
suspenseful stuff but also the beautiful
landscape I mean like that opening on
just trees and then this like Valley of
tombstones was like haunting and
striking and I love uh the way they
portray the elements POV shots and
things like that there's really
sophisticated animation there's some
lovely music as well throughout good
sound effects and whatnot
um and I mean this voice cast I think
always does a great job I always really
enjoy them it's got to be hell on a few
of those characters vocal cords
um but yeah like the inhabitants of the
train you know I thought were nice and
Eerie each of the you know both of the
Demons it's like the first one is the
big showy one and then the second one is
the philosophical one and I thought that
fit well like the more I think about it
the more as much as I can see how this
divides up into you know episodes of a
series the more I do appreciate this as
a movie and I do think that maybe even
if it doesn't a hundred percent not feel
something like an episode it does feel
pretty much like a movie overall and
again yeah just like some of those
watercolor flourishes and things like
that and some of those memories and just
that Switcheroo that sort of idea of
like we get on the train we have a bit
of fun we throw down with some demons
and it's badass and cool but wait
that's not actually what we're dealing
with that's not actually what's going on
in the Mugen train and uh yeah like I
really appreciated that left turn into
psychology and into the roots of these
characters and into again like a good
means of establishing you know the
common themes that we explore in a show
like this or in stories like this
through uh you know Shonen and whatnot
and uh yeah I'm a very satisfied Demon
Slayer fan also enjoyed the uh rangoku
is not able to expound it all on uh
Tundra's father's cockro dance but I'm
curious about that like that keeps
popping up I assume that's the guy who
keeps popping up and like giving him
Mystic Guidance with like the throat
slash and everything is his dad right
um but yeah that was interesting it too
was gonna happen uh with his black so
his unlucky sword is he gonna get a new
sword and and you know then become a
hospital once he doesn't have the black
sword I mean the black sword is pretty
badass guys ran off of the sword
everybody got at least a moment again as
much as especially zinitsu and enosuke
and nezuko are not really the focus here
they're mostly just you know physical
supporting characters occasionally
comedic supporting characters I thought
their presence was still very much
appreciated I loved again what uh
rangoku did for all of them and just
kind of witnessing and beholding his
character and sort of feeling too like
they're good at giving you the
perspective
uh of the putting you in Our Hero's
perspective where he is kind of larger
than life but you do look at him and
you're like man
I can learn from this dude you know
um so yeah man I thought this was really
really cool and I'm curious to hear what
you all thought so uh hey leave me any
of your thoughts any trivia anything
that I missed or that you want to
expound upon and uh Hey if you like this
reaction you want to see more you can
check out season one over at patreon I
believe there are watch alongs where you
sync up your own copy and reaction
highlights for most if not everything of
season one and uh we will I believe be
going to season two pretty quickly after
this is posted so uh yeah come join us
over there if you're interested and
um much love for now and as always
cheers
Chris Wham off I wanted to do a shout
out for this video and if anybody at our
patreon embodies the spirit
of the hero of this show I'm not even
sure if you watch Demon Slayer my friend
but I mean look tonjuro even in the
midst of slaying a demon is still trying
to do something good give them a moment
of peace I feel like that's how you
would approach some kind of badass
mantle of like slaying you know uh
supernatural creatures or whatever you'd
still do it with a compassion in your
heart because that's just how good of a
guy you are I want to know what your
element would be I want to see what your
costume will be like what kind of Sword
you have my dude and I'm happy that we
know you I'm happy that you're here with
us and I hope that you're doing well
much love buddy and uh
stay safe out there
[Music]